oh i'm playing full down
i feel like i've played full dan before
i played the stafford against cooldown
and got punished
but let's do it again
we'll see if cooldown is up to the
challenge
oh and then okay after this game all
i'll have to
open this opening request list
all right saffron gamut time this is
risky because i i know
oh hahaha it's halloween gambit
well i i insist on a saffron sleep shed
you'll
um involves lots of napping
that's so funny full dan full dan
transposed to halloween i insist on
stafford
and now just knight f3 what is this
i'll play d and d5 is really the only
move
that makes sense i'm down a pawn
but i feel like there's some comp
bishop g4 coming castle queenside
a bit more activity
i don't mind this
might include this uh typical pawn push
i am guillaberto thanks for subbing
with prime
yeah so i'm playing i'm playing h5
so that if white ever plays h3 the
bishop
probably doesn't have to move because of
this fishing pole
idea the other idea is just to push the
pawn
there's another very deep idea bishop
here here here here and then bishop can
get trapped
someday in the future i think the queen
is nicely placed
on f5 d4 is restricted
oh do i ever feel bad that most of the
sub in the day streams are technically
on monday
yeah they kind of carry over to monday
but some of the day is slightly
different from sunday
and then yeah it sometimes turns into
mum today
queen c2
is asking for trouble because like now i
can take and play knight d4
queen d1 i take takes takes takes rook
takes d3
i think i'm just gonna do that and get a
slightly better end game
there's no counter attack bishop e4 i
take and attack the rook
so it's endgame time i win back the pawn
i better structure more activity
if king here i wanted to get the rook in
whoa it's a raid from grand master
min lay who i know i've played before
thanks for reading very strong player
from
from vietnam right okay let's win the
pawn
yeah shout out to gm minlay
uh oh can we win another pawn
not quite but okay being up one pawn is
enough
okay let me spell this correctly so
there's gmm
get the h in
[Music]
yeah if you want to see like very high
quality especially blitz chess
people should follow men lay
if you're just joining i'm playing maybe
not the highest quality blitz chess
but i'm playing some fun let's chess oh
j j the space hound
with the staffo sub probably stands for
stafford
all right let's put the rook somewhere
more useful
i'll probably just chill i'm up upon
can be patient never scared about the
rook trade
now white's rook is slightly active
very important in these like rook
endings to activate the king and the
rook
to minimize weaknesses as much as
possible
at some point i want to play this move
thanks for subbing rylar
okay the rook is ready to infiltrate
debating between this and this or this
i'll play b6 and probably c5
i also want to play g5
opponent stops me and now if i if i do
this i um i'd
lose a pawn and white defends their own
a pawn
so what to do maybe this move
idea this and then this ready
player one also thanks for studying
with prime
can you play the london i'm always down
for london bits
next game if i'm white alexa remind me
to play the london in three minutes
okay i'll remind you in three minutes
this is okay it's a little bit strange
yeah this is probably not the most ideal
setup
but
let's just pretend it's good
i'm realizing this is not good
or is it
when in doubt pretend i could move
um
yeah i may have butchered this i can
play g5 now maybe
g5 slightly risky my my king and rook
are so awkward
now i can take this is really risky
the full down is fooling me kind of
do you ever lose tears of joy oh
do you find joy in my my losses
yeah you might find that out hopefully
not from this game though
okay this pawn is is actually kind of
dangerous
this pawn plays a crucial role in
controlling g4
so there's no no keem g4
wait am i winning i might just be
winning after rook f7
if you can ever like trade rooks
i think it's winning yeah we're trading
into a king pond ending
oh maybe it's not so simple
or is it simple it takes takes
it's not so simple or is it
wait i think i'm just promoting
unless i'm not but no here okay so the
calculation is this
this this then thankfully i have this
and this
so i'm just on time on time or in time
oh
wait a minute that's a good move this
move
if takes i just push and
[Music]
ah check
i have 10 seconds left too much time
talking
not enough time playing
it's complicated
[Music]
oops oh alexa alexa go away
alexa quiet i'm reminding you
alexa quiet what is this
no oh
[Music]
wow i got me to i couldn't stop it
either
i can't even blame alexa
oh that's so painful the under promotion
for forced mates
it promotes the queen i'm just i'm
winning because wow
good game full down what a game
ouch i guess that answers a question
from previously
do you ever lose or do you ever loose
that's a very painful loose
well-played oh
hello youtube hello youtube
yeah that was probably youtube really
unfortunately youtube people
can congratulate cool down cool down or
cool down
but on a really cool this this is more
like cool down
man i i didn't see it until it happened
i thought this was just desperation
can you play but it's
white's pieces are placed perfectly like
the king controls these squares or rook
blocks me
the pawn very important controls these
two squares
everything is set up perfectly for
whites
so i think i think i'm still winning
after king d7
but that was hard to find time travel to
the future youtube video
oh yeah and youtube people can travel
back in time
to offer their condolences
but youtube people hope you enjoy that
hope you found some pleasure in my pain
and say hi to twitchchat
and also yeah click the link in the
description i might be live
when you're watching this some sometime
in the future